a private funeral for civil rights
leader and long-time congressman
john lewis will be held next thursday in
atlanta
it will follow a week-long celebration
of his life
cbs this morning saturday co-host
michelle miller is at the edmond pettis
bridge in
selma alabama where lewis was beaten by
state troopers back in 1965. michelle
good morning
good morning as you said it will be a
full week of remembrances
and special moments beginning on
saturday
in the congressman's hometown of troy
alabama that's about
90 miles southeast of where i am there
will be a memorial at troy university
where lewis was denied entry
because of his race and where the local
library
wouldn't even issue him a library card
indignities that fueled his fighting
spirit
lewis's body will then head here to
selma of course the edmond pettis bridge
is the scene of the infamous bloody
sunday
some 55 years ago where he was badly
beaten during the march to montgomery
on sunday a processional will carry
lewis across the historic bridge before
he's taken to the alabama state capitol
that will certainly be an emotional
highlight
and on monday and tuesday lewis's body
will lie in state at the u.s
capitol building first in the rotunda
and then with social distancing rules in
effect on the east front steps for
public viewing
it's a full circle tour of the places
and the people to whom
he meant so much and we can tell you the
crew and i
and driving from georgia through the
alabama countryside
that reverence was on full display in
the church message boards
and the flags flying half staff at
public squares and barbecue joints alike
this congressman was a hero to so many
people
both big and small gail
and he deserves michelle quite the
send-off
it sounds like they have a lot planned
very very very well deserved
thank you very much michelle miller
reporting from selma